permanent un gris marché de noël à
l'endroit de nos agriculteurs et moi je
tiens à rappeler tout le mérite qu'ils
ont ce sont des métiers très difficile
ils sont là aussi pour contribuer à
notre autonomie alimentaire est
aujourd'hui faut savoir qu'il ya un
agriculteur sur trois qui a un revenu de
inférieur à 350 euros par mois donc
comment peut-on vivre décemment avec ce
revenu là on voit bien que le
gouvernement finalement a très peu fait
et le constat d'échec
l'aveu finalement du ministre de
l'agriculture est quand même assez
frappant alors qu'on a eu tout un
parcours avec des états généraux sur
l'alimentation cette fameuse loi et
galim qui devait rétablir les relations
entre agriculteurs et les producteurs et
bien est un échec c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs n'ont pas
un niveau de revenus plus élevés